they've braved the threat of militant
attacks to be here karbala the holy city
of Shiite Islam and the destination for
ashura pilgrims the grandson of the
Prophet Muhammad Imam Hussein died in
battle here pilgrims inflict wounds on
themselves in memory of his suffering
security has been high this year with
more than 20,000 police and soldiers
deployed to protect worshipers the Iraqi
government fears an attack by Islamic
state militants is controls much of
northern and western Iraq where fierce
fighting rages on these images come from
nearby G 200 kilometers north of baghdad
by G contains Iran's biggest oil
refinery responsible for a quarter of
the country's output I as captured it
over the summer government troops have
retaken it since but the struggle for
the refinery continues Iran's new
government says it wants to enlist
disaffected groups like the Kurds in the
fight against is the Peshmerga a part of
the Iraqi defense system and our support
is with them time is running out with is
threatening to take more territory
across the region